هذه هي الطريقة الأكثر أمانًا للخروج من جزر الباهاموت
ولكنها ليست آمنة حقًا على الإطلاق ، حيث يُظهر الفيديو الذي
حصلت عليه CNN مشهدًا من
مركبة مدرعة أوكرانية أن
Wasteland أصبحت المدينة ،
وقد
هربت مارينا و yevhenya من Bahamut من
مبنىهما في مركبة كهذه  كان مختبئًا في قصف
يوم الخميس الماضي ، مما أسفر عن مقتل ثلاثة من بينهم
حفيد يافانيا البالغ من العمر 33 عامًا ،
وكان علي مساعدته التي تتذكرها ، لكنني
لم أستطع فعل أي شيء
[موسيقى]
انتظروا في منازلهم المدمرة مع
الموتى لمدة ثلاثة أيام قبل أن
يتمكن الجيش من إنقاذهم
تزوجت ابنة مارينا من
حفيد ييفينيا ،
ماذا سأخبر ابنتي كريست
مارينا أنها وأحفادي في
بولندا ،
هذا المأوى القريب من chasseviar يوفر
لهم بعض الراحة والدفء لكنهم ما
زالوا خارج الخطر ،
فهذه البلدة تقع في نطاق
الأسلحة الروسية  ومنذ أن
بدأت معركة باكموت قبل سبعة أشهر ،
تعرضت بشكل منتظم للقصف
في هذا اليوم ، كان الروس يطلقون
ذخائر حارقة على المدينة
بهدف إحداث حرائق ،
أظهر لنا أحد السكان كبسولة مستهلكة من
مسؤولي الصواريخ يقولون إنه ربما يكون هناك
1000 مدني
تُركت عمليات الإخلاء في الهيكل ، لكن لا
يبدو أن هناك العديد من المحتجزين
ألكساندر يسحب حطبًا إلى المنزل ، لا توجد
كهرباء أو مياه جارية هنا ،
هرب إلى تشاسيفياتا من سيفرسك بعد ساعة
من هنا حيث تم تدمير منزله ،
هل غادر نعم لا ، أجابني
ماتت الزوجة هنا والداي مدفونان هنا
يرأس الإدارة العسكرية للبلدة
منذ أبريل الماضي ، كنا نحاول
إقناع الناس بالمغادرة والتحدث معهم
واستجوابهم أخبرني ولكن
لا يمكننا أن نجعلهم يغادرون
مرة أخرى رفض المسن والعجزة  على
المغادرة رغم خطر
بن ويتمان على سي إن إن
بشرق أوكرانيا